i guess i guess what i'm trying to
emphasize here is there's something
fundamentally different about what's
going on now versus i disagree i mean
i i i know i knew that that is what you
were saying
but
i mean
i feel it's
necessary that i remind people of the
civil rights movement and of the
uh
and of the
of the circumstances of the civil rights
movement i mean churches were being
bombed and
ruby bridges had to walk to school where
white people were yelling
racial slurs and coming to her with
literally
ropes around a black doll's neck to tell
her that they wanted to hang her and
schools were being threatened with all
of the very similarly and so i disagree
with this notion that
uh
woke fervor is somehow
radically different from say
the
uh things that were happening during
segregation in the jim crow south i mean
i think it's
it's just not objectively true
and you know you brought this point up
earlier about history i think we tend to
forget how intense that was
and equally intense and philosophically
undergirded the response to it and it
needed to be because of the intensity of
the circumstances that many of the civil
rights leaders found themselves in but
it was absolutely similar if not worse
to everything you're describing but in
this in this story where you know you
referenced daryl davis and his ability
to go and
but the clan is in disarray and sure
it's it's in a weakened state they have
no strong tenants and so it's very so
the stronger argument is the civil
rights movement but then you mentioned
this this young woman who had all these
white people screaming at her do you
think she could have walked up to one of
them and shook their hand and said we
don't have a conversation i don't i
don't think that the proper
uh thing to do
strategically is to try to go shake like
when people were
protesting segregation in the jim crow
south they weren't going up to white
supremacy to try to shake their hands no
i mean like if she went to a white rally
like a clan rally and they were saying
don't allow no because i'm saying that
at that time at that time the
circumstances were similar to what
you're describing with antifa
that's what i'm saying and yeah i agree
yes but you said it's very hard to pursu
you said it's very hard to persuade
these kinds of people but i'm saying the
civil rights movement the philosophy of
the civil rights movement understood
that what was at bottom fundamentally of
what these people what these racist
people were doing
was a lack
that a vapid lack internally that they
were projecting onto the other and so
the entire
point of the non-violent movement
stemmed from this understanding that
even as i protest you
i know that you were my brother and that
you're my sister and i'm not going to do
you harm that is and that that moved the
culture fundamentally um not only
because of the visuals of that but again
the philosophy was deeply spiritually
rooted and so i'm saying that is
precisely the kind of response that is
required in these days and times we
we've uh some we've had a few leftists
on this show and it's very difficult
for a few reasons yeah it's not just
about fundamental disagreements yeah
some people just want to exploit the
show
and potentially cause it harm and we
watch out for that so like we might
book someone will come on and then start
breaking all the rules on purpose and
trying to get us banned oh uh and
i think um that's wild oh yeah yeah we
have yeah there are people who have
tried to exploit the show and we're like
i know their game we're not gonna you
know yeah uh because they they don't
like us and i think the other is there's
a fear of
i guess
excommunication cancel culture okay so
there have been instances where people
are like look i'd love to come on the
show but i just can't deal with that
kind of heat
and other people have dealt with this
too very prominent uh figures on youtube
in the culture war have their guests get
harassed relentlessly for coming on and
it scares them away and say i can't do
this
but we have had a few different leftists
on the show have been willing to come on
and we are absolutely uh i thought they
went very very well yeah i don't know if
we can say we're we're you know we're
friends because i wouldn't want i
wouldn't impose it on them but i thought
we got along swimmingly yeah and we've
had vosh friends on the show a couple
times and uh ian's a big fan i love him
wait are you talking he's a big fan of
me his name's ian awesome you're both
fans yeah he's a big fan of ian yeah and
so i actually i've i've really enjoyed
uh having you know vosh you know coming
on he's a socialist he's
very left he was pro-biden you know a
lot of things we disagree with um he's
he's i i think it's fair to say he's pro
crt and all that stuff okay and you know
what happens is after the show we're
talking d and d and video games
and that's right that's always what
happens yeah exactly it's like hey you
know like we're we are not uh i i like
you you might notice we have this poster
here uh back there shout out to brent
lengle of snow white zombie apocalypse
so we argue on facebook all the time and
he's a lefty guy and and i'm like kind
of but i'm not authoritarian i'm very
libertarian so like policy comes second
to freedom to me and uh
you know he he put up a kickstarter for
this and i was like i thought it looked
really cool yeah i was like i liked the
art i thought it was fantastic so i was
like i'll i'll pitch it for this
kickstarter and i posted about it saying
look me and this guy we argue all the
time but i have no no animosity or hard
feelings towards i actually enjoy you
know having these discussions and and
it's never uh i think in this instance
we're not screaming at each other and
insulting each other because we're good
people yeah and there are bad people on
twitter who just want to say nasty words
yeah but my point was like if we focused
on the things that we had more in common
maybe we'd actually better understand
each other the things we don't have in
common absolutely or actually just learn
how we can live together to get get
through these certain things but i gotta
tell you it's really really challenging
with a mainstream media apparatus that
would say something like joe rogan took
horse medicine
that kind of stuff um the example i
always use sorry audience for beating a
dead horse
no pun intended democrats believe the
economy is good
independent voters and republicans
believe the economy is not good mm-hmm
oh i saw you posted this it is yeah it
is objectively true the economy is not
good
um i suppose there are some metrics
where you could like isolate one
specific thing like well the
unemployment rate went down by 0.2
percent yes but that doesn't make a good
economy when you have
500 000 expectation jobs how is it that
democratic voters think the economy is
good right now no i mean new york
businesses are losing money because of
the mandates
they're speaking about they're
complaining about it major shortages
price increases
it's just bad i mean we had record job
openings 10.1 million last month and
then we only filled 235 000 they
expected 800 or whatever like we still
have a massive we have mass resignations
people are quitting their jobs but
people live in the matrix
you know what i mean so that that what
makes it really really difficult is
when you try and even invite someone to
come on
and they're like i'm not gonna go on a
nazi show or something because the media
said bad words yeah you know what i mean
yeah i mean you got to take it all in
stride
but how do you how would you navi like
so i i agree with you in a lot of what
you said you know about you know like
meeting people as just a person not for
the sake of winning or persuading but
how do you how do you navigate people
who are constantly inundated by lies and
deception to keep them away from you
you understand that you are not and
cannot be omnipotent and you cannot
control everything and you accept
the good and the bad and you roll with
the punches
but what if you're trying to what if
you're trying to make sure and you're
like i mean look
it's i i suppose i
i agree
but it might be a bit pessimistic like
as if to say that i'm watching a
building fall down knowing there's
nothing i can do to stop it see that's
very interesting because i i do think
that i'm pretty optimistic
and um
i know there are no guarantees with
anything
but i do believe in culture i actually
believe in culture these days far more
than i believe in politics and i think
that the culture is actually far more
robust
uh
and gives us the space to have
conversations with people which with
whom we disagree and
and i think that maybe if you
in addition to you know meeting people
in order to get to know them and things
like that leaned into the culture more
than the politics i would be curious
where that would get you in terms of how
you perceive others and how others
perceive you i agree you know so we we
have the cass castle vlog which is like
it's the next it's the latest show that
we launched we've got a couple of the
other shows we're launching one's going
back mysteries we've done
uh we've done like recordings of it and
we're doing music and editing and stuff
could be fun yeah and the reason we
started doing the vlog there's two big
reasons one is like man the new stuff we
do is so negative all the time yeah i
know like ian points it out it's like
all we do is highlight this bad stuff
and i'm like we gotta hide like fun good
stuff yeah and so the vlog is like we
have baby chickens look how cute they
are they're growing up they're getting
big and now they're looking goofy
because they're in that puberty stage
where they have some feathers but not
looking they look really weird yeah and
so the goal of the vlog is just to be
like fun and inspirational for sure
building culture that's dope i i one of
the complaints i have about the
republicans because i you know i i think
i think we used to have a unit party the
democrats and republicans were like the
same thing yeah then the you know the
right-wing populists kind of busted in
the republican party but the republicans
still very much think the path towards
victory is like appointing judges yeah
i think trump supporters understand
that's not the case
it's the cultural institutions
that's going to shape the future okay
and what
where
what are the cultural institutions the
apprentice
that was one of them the office
the office so tv shows oh absolutely for
example tv film and yeah colleges
colleges
media yeah
yeah
i was uh man i've been watching reruns
of 30 rock you ever watched i literally
just started restarted watching 30 rock
that is that is
uncanny
today maybe maybe netflix just like
recommended 30 rock because i was
thinking about it for some reason it's
the first show i watched when i moved to
new york um and so yeah i love that show
and it's a show that couldn't be made
today yes yeah and that's the issue you
know what really
was like a knife in the heart
was when i'm watching i think it's like
the third episode and tina fey i don't
know i mean it's like the i don't know
what episode it is but uh um jenna
is doing a photo shoot for maxim yeah
and
there's like loud noise and a fan or
whatever and the guy interviewing her
asks her about the war and she says
something but you can't hear it and he
writes down i hate the troops
and so there's this big thing in a
magazine saying that she hates the
troops and tina fey is like or you know
liz lemon why did you say that she goes
i didn't say that he misheard me in
those protests
but anyway she says okay you know jack
donaghy goes we're putting you on
hardball with tucker carlson and chris
matthews to debate this so good and then
liz says something like
just say the war was started under false
pretenses and it was horribly planned
and that you respect the troops and
don't blame them for this and i was just
like man where did that rhetoric go
where where was that left obama
he came in saying he was going to fix it
and then didn't and a lot of it got left
the baggage got left in his garage i
will just add to finish the joke because
it was amazing
she calls tucker carlson very attractive
which is fun
because they would never allow that yeah
they would never allow tucker carlson to
appear and be called attractive he was
on msnbc and she says something it's
really funny because it's 2007 she said
i think the government needs to hunt
down obama and that's why i'm voting for
osama in 2008
and that's 30 rock you couldn't you
couldn't get away with any of that such
a good show thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time